spots Phil Spencer good morning and
welcome investing in and shipping new
exclusive franchises is critical to our
platform success we're proud to partner
with in a few nice on mark Puccini and
the teams that concept in armature
studios to create recore and exclusive
new first party franchise for xbox one
at Xbox our mission is simple to put you
the gamers at the center of everything
we do to build the best platform and
most reliable service for both gamers
and developers and to enable teams to
push the boundaries of creativity
technical innovation and of course fun
today you will see how we're continuing
to invest in innovate for gamers across
our platform our service our devices and
of course our games anchored by first
party exclusives will see a lineup of
games from creators developers and
publishers of all sizes that show the
breadth depth and diversity of the games
you will get to play on xbox these games
make up what I believe is the greatest
games lineup in Xbox history
[Applause]
since the launch of Xbox one we've
listened to you the community of xbox
gamers and we're grateful for your
continued feedback we continue to
deliver monthly platform feature updates
that enhance your gaming experience and
your response to the updates continues
to motivate us last year the team
decided to tackle a feature that has
been consistently at the top of your
request list and while we weren't sure
it was possible today I'm pleased to
announce Xbox one backward compatibility
your xbox 360 games
the games you've invested your time and
money in and the games you want to
continue to be play will be playable
natively on your xbox one our goal is to
deliver the largest games catalog ever
on xbox and xbox one backward
compatibility allows us to do just that
please welcome my cube are ahead of our
platform engineering team to show us
xbox one backward compatibility in
action Mike thanks fell will have over
100 titles this holiday with hundreds
more added in the months to come digital
xbox 360 titles will start showing up
automatically in your game library on
xbox one and retail discs will work as
well put your disc in download the game
and you're ready to go let's take a look
with one of my favorite xbox 360 games
this is mass effect on Xbox one
[Applause]
the game runs exactly like it does on
xbox 360 but better thanks to the power
of xbox live xbox take a screenshot
you'll get to play multiplayer with your
friends on xbox 360 and you'll get to
take advantage of xbox one features like
screenshots broadcasting game DVR and
game streaming with the Xbox app on
Windows 10 we made this easy for game
developers to they just need to approve
title showing up no work is required on
their part to make all of this possible
an initial set of backward compatible
titles are available today for Xbox
preview members it will be available for
everyone this holiday with xbox one
backward compatibility we won't charge
you to play the games you already own
thanks and I'll see you on xbox live
[Applause]